elle était attendue pour cadrer le grand
débat national la lettre du président de
la république a donné des détails sur
son contenu
il se déroulera du 15 janvier au 15 mars
avec un rôle essentiel donnée au maire
qualifié d'intermédiaires légitime de
l'expression des citoyens par le chef de
l'état avant d'être maire je suis aussi
un citoyen comme tout le monde et à ce
titre j'ai aussi j'ai aussi des idées en
nous aujourd'hui puisqu'elle présentera
publics s'appuient sur les mers et c'est
une bonne chose si on peut contribuer à
faire comprendre à l'état et aux
parlementaires que les élus locaux en
tout cas que la décentralisation ou le
renforcement de leur compétence est
important pour justement faire en sorte
de répondre aux polonais du quotidien
des habitants
quatre thématiques fiscalité et dépense
publique organisation de l'état
transition écologique et démocratie
précisant qu'il n'y aura pas de thème
interdite emmanuel macron ajoute
plusieurs questions quels impôts faut-il
à vos yeux baissés en priorité faut-il
renforcer la décentralisation et donner
plus de pouvoirs de décision et d'action
au plus près des citoyens
quelles propositions concrètes
feriez-vous pour accélérer notre
transition environnementale ou faut-il
reconnaître le vote blanc je pense que
je suis vraiment dans le flou aussi
stratégique puisse-t-elle être cette
lettre je pense que c'est un une bonne
chose c'est bien voilà c'est un bon
début maintenant je suis assez sceptique
qu'est ce qui va se passer pendant ce
débat est ce qu'on va rester à attendre
voilà et ensuite le cnes qui en sortira
j'attends de voir
évidemment il ya aussi l'urgence c'est
le pouvoir d'achat et là il ya des tas
de forme pour augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat
ça peut être une hausse des salaires ça
peut être aussi une baisse de la tva ou
voir la tva à taux zéro sur des produits
de première nécessité interrogation
aussi du côté de certains élus yvelinois
comme la sénatrice sophie primas sur les
questions soulevées par le président de
la république et sur l'organisation du
débat comme le conseiller départemental
yves vandewalle doutes sur la finalité
dans les yvelines le préfet a nommé un
référent aux grands débats il s'agit de
sans roberti la préfecture aura un rôle
de facilitateur et non d'organisateur